not every Harry Potter star made it
through all eight movies a few of them
are switched out for a wide range of
reasons including death run-ins with the
law and embarrassing scandals here are
some of the major Harry Potter
characters who were ultimately recast
between films and the stories of how
those transfigurations came to be
although there's still plenty of potter
fans who prefer richard Harris's
depiction of Dumbledore the role was
nonetheless recast ahead of Harry Potter
and the Prisoner of Azkaban after the
two-time Oscar winner passed away in
2002 from Hodgkin's disease Paris had
expected that he might not be able to
carry on in the role forever which he
first took to please his granddaughter
he told the press that I'll keep doing
it as long as I enjoy it my help holds
out and they still want me but the
chances of all three of those factors
remaining constant are pretty slim the
part would eventually go to Michael
Gambon who starred in all six following
films but Gambon wasn't the only British
star invited to dawn two heaping wig and
decadent cloaks years after the fact Sir
Ian McKellen revealed that he too had a
shot at becoming Albus Dumbledore but
turned it down I couldn't I I couldn't
take over the part from an actor who I'd
known didn't approve Harris had
reportedly been unimpressed with
McKellen's career implying that he was a
passionless actor despite all this
McKellen added that he sometimes saw
himself on posters which featured Gambon
as Dumbledore when Lord Voldemort first
appeared on screen and Harry Potter and
the Sorcerer's Stone there wasn't a lot
for the actor portraying him to do after
all he was mostly hidden behind
professor Quarles turban throughout the
story and even when he did emerge his
face was superimposed on the back of
Quarles skull Richard Brimmer did what
he could with the role but wasn't
surprised when he wasn't invited back to
reprise his part in Harry Potter and the
Goblet of Fire
Bremer told this is northeast the
producers spent a long time fighting to
get me so I'm very proud to have been
the first but the role is now being
played by ray Fiennes who's an old mate
in the fourth film I've been in the
business a long time and it didn't
surprise me that they went for a bigger
name being Hollywood lead and I'm happy
to pass it on to Wraith signs was
already an a-lister by the time
Sorcerer's Stone was released having won
Oscar nominations for Schindler's List
and The English Patient
it's no surprise that the filmmakers
didn't seek him out for that brief CGI
appearance Jaime wale it did an apt
enough job as Draco Malfoy's pastry
loving henchman vincent crabbe
like many of his contemporaries in the
series the young actor was completely
new to the world of film when he suited
up as the Slytherin sycophant but was
gradually given more and more screen
time throughout his sixth film tenure by
the time Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows arrived however Krabs other half
Gregory Goyle was seen standing next to
a new Malfoy lieutenant blaze Sabini
Crabbe was completely out of the picture
and while the role itself wasn't recast
the character was shuffled out of sight
to make room for Sabini this all stemmed
from wale it's off-camera run-ins with
the law Whelan was arrested in 2009
after he was caught growing marijuana
plants in his mother's home that
incident alone was enough to lose him
his prime position in the Potter world
and the troubles would only continue
from there the actor was later arrested
again in 2012 for participating in a
riot and this time he faced jail way
let's go star Jesse cave would later
publicly rise to his defense but the
damage was still done and the actor
hasn't worked on a film since when the
Gryffindor common room portrait known as
the fat lady first appeared in Harry
Potter and the Sorcerer's Stone it was
celebrated actress Elizabeth Spriggs who
portrayed her however Spriggs portrayal
was brief and rather rigid in blithely
asking for the prefect password so
before the character would return in
Harry Potter and the Prisoner of Azkaban
the actress was replaced with Don French
French brought a more comedic element to
the character as she desperately tries
to impress the Hogwarts student body
with her glass breaking operatic skills
[Applause]
[Applause]
French earned the role after her Harry
Potter spoof for charity caught the
attention of director and producer
Christopher Columbus Columbus told the
BBC
I think she's incredibly funny and her
Harry Potter spoof for comic relief was
pretty amazing the casting of the Harry
Potter films was entirely limited to
British thespians a rule so strict it
even forced producers to turn down Robin
Williams for the role of Hagrid but
verne troyer became the rare exception
when he was cast as Gringotts banker
Griphook in Harry Potter and the
Sorcerer's Stone Troyer was the only
American actor with a major role in the
film but the character was voiced by his
English co-star Warwick Davis who also
portrayed Professor Flitwick and another
bank teller in the film but by the time
Griphook became more significant to the
story in Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hollows Davis had taken over the role
completely Grip who has so much more
depth to him that uh never been able to
get into my work as Professor Flitwick
and so I went in and read for David
Yates though it was never reported as
the reason for Troy's replacement the
actor had been caught up in a number of
embarrassing scandals following the
first film's release